bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono parigi oggi mi sono ricordato
che esiste presto disegna una rete
neurale che puoi imparare a riconoscere
i disegni punto interrogativo che
mettono il punto interrogativo perché io
faccio disegni da cani quindi non
riconosce niente agevole il suo
apprendimento aggiungendo i tuoi disegni
alla più vasta raccolta di disegni del
mondo fammi vedere
ah che bello questo question disegni
fatti bene un gatto un ginocchio un
elefante sono fatti bene aspettate che
arrivo io disegna una piuma c'è lui
prova indovinarla e io la disegno quindi
signori siamo tutti qua per supportarmi
supportate mi fate il tifo per me mentre
di segno grazie
vedo una linea aspetta oppure uno spazio
libero papa soffre cose cosi della piuma
no vedo una matita ai cosi della piuma
pure un asparago è una piuma si vede dai
questo il gabbiano vedo un pennarello
ma a parte gli scherzi ragazzi vede che
una piuma si vede un ottimo ma come un
occhio a indovinare malocchio vale un
occhio e ma tu sorella un occhio ma va
bene allora va bene tutto però pure tu
mamma mi avesse così stupida per
cortesia disegna una motocicletta
motocicletta difficile è però ci
proviamo costruire un centro non è
dominato la piuma prima della
maturazione bella aspetta oppure una
ruota gira l'aspetta un attimo un
cannone come un cannone non aspetta
aspetta cicchitto che la piena nonno
bicicletta soli quasi non riesco a
indovinare 112 one peccato perché ci sei
porta va accadendo in tempo i 20 secondi
siccome sono pochi 20 secondi però una
sirena sirena easy dai è colpa mia la
sirena è fatta male di una rana l'ho
fatta
non riesco a indovinare l'ho fatta
malissimo la velina calcolati cola l'ho
fatta malissimo devo fare una roba ma io
credo di avere dei limiti nel disegno e
stesso io penso una cosa ma non riesco a
fare l'attrice
io penso a una roba ma non riesco a fare
quello che penso questo il mio limite
grosso nel disegno se io dico cavolo
vorrei disegnarla
poi lo faccio ma non riesco a fare
quello che nella mia mente si crea
questo è il mio limite del disegno
oppure sono semplicemente un
rincoglionito un rossetto beh dai questo
abbastanza decisi lo faccio anche con la
perina è una linea oppure dei fiammiferi
per oppure un grattacielo eccolo vedo un
pastello no oppure una scopa che scopo
oppure un pennello è un rosso in teoria
dai un rossetto madonna è facile dio ti
prego per a facilissimo ma sei stupida
un castello dal castello easy veloce
vedo dei fiammiferi ma che più ami però
è un castello brava brava sembrava un
piede con tre dita ma va bene vediamo
come l'ha disegnato la gente la sirena
vediamo quello disegnata io allora la
sirena va fatta così giustamente lo
farveli che sembrava molto e io volevo
fare un pò questo solo che ho fatto
questo lo vedremo indietro si preoccupa
gioca di nuovo e dopo che lo facevo sto
gioco grazie a dio sono riuscito a
riportarlo torre eiffel dai retta un
attimo una linea
lo so è la torrese e siamo o ragazzi
l'obiettivo di questo video and fire
indovinare 6 non è facile lo so però già
una radio lo so è una radio
siamo 2 0 2 un orecchio va bene vi do
una lampada da pavimento una lampada lo
so è un orecchino a tornare su sei un
autobus eco l'autobus un casinò alla
festa la ruota matura ghani uno scherano
aspetta all'oceano
che fastidio ma oppure un treno non è un
treno infine tante fine lo so sono
bravissimo
dai dai dai dai ragazzi dai dai altalena
vedo un trampolino allora lo so è un al
terremoto onna madonna una pizza ragazzi
chiudiamo con l'italiano cavolo
concorrere di thun ce l'ho fatta storta
oppure un mentino oppure uno no tu no no
no quasi pure una nuova moda e non ho
idea di che cosa sta accadendo
lo so è una pizza fatto bei disegni bay
disgrazie grazie bei disegni io la mia
pizza era fantastica grazie bei disegni
sei fantastico comunque io sono stato
bravissimo credo che la cosa che mi sia
venuta meno la torre eiffel ma perché
non mi ha fatto finire volevo fare tutte
intersezioni sono bravo la pubblico su
twitter vediamo cosa pensa la gente
la radio sembra più un autobus dell'auto
pur se stesso vediamo e vero è vero la
torre eiffel e più bella dell'originale
importante con qualcuno e fatela
restaurare effettivamente non ci hai
tutti i torti
però ti si impegnato zia tu non sai
neanche quanto un'altalena così non
l'avevo mai visto sempre più uno
strumento di tortura beh se ci pensi
effettivamente non ci ha proprio tutti i
torti però tutti appendi a quei cavi e
tipo saw l'enigmista
andiamo avanti ragazzi coi disegni un
paio di forbici vedo la luna ma che luna
oppure un cerchio no guarda è un paio di
foto grazie ma sai che mi piace questo
gioco io mi sono qui innamorato della
narratrice cioè quella voce ma sexy che
mi piace un cappello è passato un botto
dall'ultima volta che non ha indovinato
e quindi fantastico otto di fila un
pennello
vedo una linea retta vedo un pennarello
è un pennello fiori un pastello non
pennellatore un amate un pennello morta
tua sorella un pennello non ho idea di
come un pennello lighty precorso nick di
colori dai ma riesco indovina porco
demonio dai perché una clessidra va bene
una crescita come quella che ho rotto in
esperimento incredibile lino oppure un
quella che avevo fatto io la rotta è un
aggressiva un secchio va bene col
secchio
vedo un cerchio no ho sbagliato oppure
una patata è parlato di una cosa che
facciamo vedo un fagiolino fagiolino
vedo un naso vetta oppure un barattolo
di pittura dai un sé ma che lo so è un
secchio barattolo di pittura babbi
secchio dopo venne dopo è un casino con
gli animali purtroppo di questo problema
macché oppure lo zig zag che pure di
fiammiferi
macché fiammiferi oppure un esito
poligano ragazzo oppure un delfino è un
topo dai è un topo molto bene per quanto
riguarda il pennello che era il migliore
di tutti e guardate gli altri il
pennello non la indovinato come la retta
pensato il disegno somigliasse uno di
questi una chitarra un treno un
pennarello ma guarda lo guarda ho fatto
anche il costo sembra simbolo da
vodafone
vediamo cosa ne pensate di questi vedi
vedi il pennello l'unica cosa perfetta
non è stato indovinato che dire hai
visto
ma allora non sono stupido io guardavo
c'è veramente è bellissimo il pennello
per siete pazzi
più che un topo con lo sembrano dog ok
il sun of rome avere ci ho provato
ultimamente ci sta la città pensata
questa bellissima dopo missile le
disegna un teschio in meno di 20 secondi
dai andiamo col teschio ragazzi che
lavoro difficile quello del punitore
mamma mia ragazzi un giorno però vennero
politico venderò questi quadri di un
giorno lo farò per voi a milioni di euro
perché verranno un sacco una sveglia
vedo un orecchio aspetta pure un cerchio
che non sveglia di quelle antiche un
vedo un biscotto oppure la luna sveglia
porco demonio la sveglia buonarroti
penati ma che tigre pure te il pane una
faccina sorridente vedo un naso ma dai
lo so è una faccina sorridente bomba mia
ragazza un ghiacciolo va bene a ostia ma
cede
e io vado in portorico grazie il
violoncello ecco il violoncello
potrebbero dei problemi allora così
lungo mi aspetta un secondo porco
demonio che i politici ginocchio
pinocchio oppure un tappo di bottiglia
quindi sono poi non in diretta la grande
muraglia c'è miglio roncello violoncello
ma mi sa che il violoncello e quello più
grosso quindi dovevo fare uno che lo
teneva mannaia la morte una piscina va
bene prova a farlo non ne sono sicuro la
facciamo qui alla schiava la vita mia
sono sicuro dalla piscina oppure un
grattacielo
vedo un telecomando ma che telecom amore
è un trampolino ma pure una nave da
crociera vai prata e una piscina oppure
un forno a microonde è una piscina dai è
una piscina all'ultimo secondo l'ha
indovinata va bene teschio la sveglia è
morta la faccina sorridente il
ghiacciolo un violoncello il violoncello
e inguardabile condividiamo tutto su
twitter la sveglia mi ricorda la mia
vita tutta roba che poi ha
scarabocchiato lo è non scarabocchiato
più questa faccina esprime la mia voglia
di morire per il caldo e guarda caso
sotto c'è anche il mezzo
beh ma proprio non capisco ma che fate
non indovinare sveglia
io quando esco da una crisi isterica no
vabbè ragazzi è stato un problema hai
fatto l'artistico no però avrei voluto
quello è l'unico teschio che non fa
paura effettivamente vi sfido ad aver
paura consta roma però andiamo avanti
cestino allora cestino dovrebbe essere
abbastanza i limiti ma che mirtillo sono
confusa sono confusa dai 1 sentire le
cose york a vacca che bambino si può
indovinare un autobus
vedo uno scuolabus comporre un
clarinetto 1 scuola non riesco a
indovina cosa cook perché è quell ora
più scuolabus che autobus un biscotto o
i cookie li faccio bene è un disco delle
pinze o alle pizze che non si parla la
pinza intendi quelle per tre le presine
dei punti di sutura di sutura queste
pinze una spiaggia va bene vedo un
oceano
oppure la migrazione degli animali
situazione degli animali vedo la grande
muraglia ci vedi la grande muraglia è
una spia grazie un cacciavite la pinza e
casamento 30 cielo oppure un pennarello
lo so è un cacciavite la spiaggia è
bellissimo io spero che questo video sia
stato di vostro gradimento
la casa bianca qua mi ha chiamato mica
per caso c'è nel senso io faccio dei
disegni che possono aiutare un intero
paese contattatemi ragazzi governi
contattatemi spero che arrivi sia
piaciuto con la sentenza viene
rilasciato un commento è un mi piace
anche ai vari dj non scherza disegnino
però iscrivetevi al canale schiaccia
della campanella così rimanete
aggiornati sui nuovi video che escono e
noi come sempre ci vediamo a un prossimo
disegno beh ragazzi
[Musica]